also there's this a member of a Boston
suburbs Human Rights Commission resigned
after posting in a profanity-laden post
to Facebook last week that mocked God
and cursed her fellow citizens amid
controversy regarding a local library's
Christmas trees
so the town of Dedham Massachusetts
about 30 miles Southwest of Boston to
national attention after Lisa Desmond
the manager of the local Endicott Branch
Library wrote on Facebook earlier this
month that its annual Christmas tree
display had apparently been canceled to
prevent offending people Desmond wrote
I've never posted a negative post on
Facebook that is until now I found out
today that my beautiful Library will not
have its Christmas tree this year when I
asked I was told that people were made
uncomfortable last year looking at it
sorry what in my 28 years of uh at the
library I have never heard a negative
comment
uh yeah because it was probably just one
person I mean how can you I I don't care
what your religion is if you don't have
a religion
it doesn't even seem physically possible
to uh
conjure feelings of anger or revulsion
when you're looking at a Christmas tree
it's just a it's a naturally joyous it's
like doesn't it make anyone smile to see
a Christmas tree could even make me
smile so how could you manage
to actually be upset
stewing and anger looking at a Christmas
tree
of all things
well most people can't there's probably
one person so for 28 years they had a
Christmas tree no problems no one ever
expressed one single
um ounce of of anger about it
one person comes along after almost
three decades and says you know I really
don't like that okay well yes sir we'll
take it right down
Desmond noted that the town historically
has celebrated and included everyone in
our community and she happily
participated in a recent Juneteenth
celebration at the library last summer
uh Diane loud Who was appointed to the
Human Rights Commission in Massachusetts
by the town's Commission on disability
reportedly called Desmond a selfish
effing bee and a subsequent Facebook
post that accused her of endangering
lives by raising the issue
she wrote for a tree for a mother effing
tree you've put people's lives in a lot
of danger a lot of danger
so a Christmas tree puts people's lives
in danger
I'm not exactly sure maybe if the tree
falls over on you or if it
if it's a real tree and you're not
watering it enough then it could become
a fire hazard I mean that's real so is
that what you means I don't think so
addressing others she speculated might
also have been responsible for bringing
the controversy to wider attention loud
continued in part
I hope you know the fact that you who
claim to Believe In Christ and Christmas
or whatever happy horse s you're trying
to hide behind are the least gracious
most hateful most disgusting trash in
the world
is this what you think your magic Sky
daddy wants where in the Bible was this
again
in closing I would like to add an F you
you pieces of trash
I hate each and every one of you and I
do wish great suffering on you you're
terrible terrible people you did it all
because you didn't get your way you're
despicable
this is about a Christmas tree
I always thought that the story of like
the Grinch who stole Christmas was it
was you know it's a little hard to get
invested in because it's just not very
realistic like how could anyone hate
Christmas that much but here here we go
this is the person that the story was
based on I guess
um
and uh it says allowed participated
earlier this year in an LGBT Pride event
hosted by the town of Dedham and it's
HRC Human Rights Commission where she
was joined by her by her grown child Max
who discovered his transgender identity
at the age of 13. all right big surprise
there so
so Diane loud with with a very
appropriate last name I must say sounds
like a just a deeply miserable person a
horrendously unpleasant human being all
around no wonder she has a trans kid
she's exactly the kind of adult
exactly the kind of especially over
domineering uh left-wing mentally
unstable mother
who ends up having a trans child just by
coincidence no it's not a coincidence
because she imposes that identity on her
child
um no surprise there
but I really want to focus on the fact
that
she's an anti-christian atheist
with the Human Rights Commission or she
was with the Human Rights Commission
and this is this is a problem that goes
far beyond just this one individual so
it's a bigger issue
um and I'm sure this never occurred to
her because she doesn't seem like the
sort of person who makes a habit of you
know thinking much less thinking
self-critically
but
you cannot be involved in protecting or
preserving human rights
as an anti-christian atheist
it doesn't really make any sense
it doesn't and as I said this is a
problem that goes far beyond Mrs loud
I'm going to say Miss loud because I'm
assuming she's not married
um
it goes far beyond that
it's like if you're if you're an atheist
your secular leftist
and you go around talking about human
rights all the time you've got a real
issue here because what do you think
like what is a woman well what is a what
is a human right
what do you think a human right even is
where do you think it comes from
what are you talking about
now the people who came up with the
concept the concept as we understand it
today
and if you want to you know if you want
to trace back the the lineage of this
thought process that that led to the
formulation of modern human rights as we
understand it you know you can decide
how far back you want to go
but the people came up with a concept as
we understand it they've formulated sort
of the modern understanding of Human
Rights these were Christians
and it's very much grounded in a
Christian worldview of natural law
um of human beings created by God
endowed by by certain rights because it
just which which we we have as uh you
know thanks to our inherent dignity and
all of this is rooted in the fact that
we are created by this Transcendent
being that there is something beyond the
physical
um
that we are not merely
subject to and products of darwinian
evolution there's something beyond that
that's human rights
as it's always been understood
but if you don't believe any of that and
if you think as Diane Lau does that all
that is a bunch of happy horse s
then how how do you how do you hang on
to the human rights what do you think
that's grounded in
a human right must either come from if
it means anything at all
it either comes from God
or it comes from man it comes from the
government
so either this is a human right is
something that's ingrained that we just
that we possess
whether it's recognized by the
government or not you just we still
possess it
by our very nature so it's either that
or it's simply
words that we write on a piece of paper
you know governments decide what your
rights are
you have the right to do this because
the government said you do
and if they say you don't then you don't
anymore
but nobody wants to understand human
rights that way
they certainly don't on the left
now when the Supreme Court made the
decision about Roe v Wade
we were told that by the left including
many of them secular atheists
they they said well no this is it
doesn't matter what the Supreme Court
says women have the right to abortion
what do you mean right
who says who
what are you appealing to exactly when
you when you talk about this mystical
right that that exists you're not
appealing to God what are you appealing
to
if you can only appeal to man if you can
only appeal to the government then it's
up to them what the rights are and it
doesn't make any sense if the government
says you have a right to this it doesn't
make any sense to say no that's that's
not true what do you mean it's not true
according to you a right by definition
is simply whatever the government says
this is a real problem but I don't think
anyone on the left has even attempted
there are very few people on the left
have even attempted to confront or deal
with or wrestle with
um and it just makes everything they say
about human rights totally meaningless
and I'll do it for this portion of the
show as we move over to the members
block hope to see you there if not talk
to you tomorrow Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]